[Music]
hello everybody I want to talk about
something that it has been extremely
late has been talk during the entire
next we have had several presentations
talking about SLS and every budget but
I'm going to focus a little bit more
into how everything applies once you get
paid once you like your call and how you
set up everything in a way that allows
you to receive those pages that don't
wake up the way you have in the middle
of the night we're going to try to talk
same I'd also like a commutative so
we're going to try to understand the
reality of complex systems understand
what matters to our business and to our
users understand tolerance
understand how to use systems symptoms
as a way to pages and then putting
everything together so raise your hand
if you have ever been on call raise your
hand if you have ever been on call in
the middle of the night keep your hand
up if you have been paid
and once you go to your computer the
problem was not there anymore okay so
you're in the right place most of him
so physical monitoring is hard like it's
a message like there are plenty of
monitoring systems then that are
alerting for things that once you get
there like they think it's not there
anymore like how many times has an
ambulance being called to just show up
and then it was just somebody that that
had a little bit of legged this made
like lose consciousness but he's like
back to you or you call the fireman the
building is evacuated and there's no
fire it's just like somebody putting a
like cooking or or doing something
similar there are many times that you
receive those pages mostly because when
you start a new service when you start
your your company you're like working
with small systems they're paging
forward like the cost is like the things
that are related to you like machine is
out of memory the CPU is like very hard
things that matter to your service once
once you start but he started not
marrying so much when the service starts
growing like the mortgage of service
grows the more machines you have in
their service and there is a lack of
correlation between how your service
grows and how your operational sorry
there is it usually
relation when their service size
increases and your system has a certain
capacity for the operational team there
is about operational situation if your
operational load increases at the same
level as your service size increases the
ideal situation is that use your
operational work grows linearly compared
to your to your service size and that is
really difficult to do when you can have
the system base alerting system that i'm
going to describe continiously sorry
so some saying another thing on CPU is
starvation memory starvation it's very
normal to be done when you have small
machine small set of machines but the
data center is scale it doesn't make
much sense when you have like thousands
of machines that are running imagine
getting page for any of those machines
running out of memory it doesn't even
make sense at the level of the data
center like people working in the data
center should only get paged
when a certain number of machines are
running out of space or when a certain
number of machines are broken not for
every single one of those machines would
that happens you're actually having like
data center operators running up and
down in the data center like replacing a
single disk on several machines in fact
that Google we have perfection
the idea of repairing a certain number
of machines when they have to be
repaired and we actually trace the path
that the operator has to do in order to
go repair those machines so single
single cause
alerting it's definitely not a way to do
it in fact if you do the math I have
here a assertion that 5,000 machines
running for a single day is more than 10
years machine of a single machine
running took 10 years in fact it's like
something like 13 for 69 plus years it's
just a comparison it's it's not a
one-to-one comparison but it's to give
you an idea of how long a single machine
should be running to compare to those
thousand machines running in a
datacenter there are plenty other things
that you have to take into account like
the mean time before failure and like
the bathtub curve in like the beginning
you get a lot of failures in the
machines because it's like new
components and they haven't been tested
then you have a flat line and then you
start like getting alert getting
errors and breakages at the end of the
lifecycle but essentially the idea is
that running a set of a very complex
system with a large set of machines
increases the number of error of the
yoga negative so it doesn't make sense
at all to page four in single one in
fact one of the principles when we
design the precursor of kubernetes board
it was that is however failures is not a
question of if they're gonna fail is a
question of when they're gonna fail so
essentially what we did at Google was
incorporating the idea of paging only
when the user experience is affected so
we move away from paging from individual
concepts to paging only when the when
there is a symptom that reflects user
happiness only page when the user has
been affected when the user figures out
that there is a problem with the system
so now that we know that we don't page
for individual machines going down and
we only page for when the users are
being affected let's talk about how we
engineer that ever that we are receiving
a rear saying in our systems in our in
our paging Ben trainer came up with the
idea that 100 percent is the wrong
reliability for almost everything I
would argue that it's impossible to
achieve in order to have 100%
reliability you would have to know
exactly the state of every single of
your components in your entire system at
all times during the entire lifetime of
those components in fact the user is not
going to know that your system is not
100% reliable because once you get into
an elevator who has a mobile phone how
many times you in the middle of a phone
call and then you get into an elevator
and then you cannot continue that phone
call
exactly it happens that error is
introduced not only by the system but by
your environment so it doesn't make
sense to try to embrace that it's sorry
to try to fix those errors it's better
to embrace them because things will fail
things will break like during the
natural life cycle of the things you
will have hundreds of users that will
try to use your system
when there is the final of the of the
American football when there is a an
earthquake in a different location
people will go to your service to try to
figure out what's happening people will
go to pay when there is a dip on the
Bitcoin or to get the bitcoins out of
your your system also users will try to
use your service in a way that it was
not designed for Google Maps had a
certain pic of use when people figured
out that they could get the tiles of the
maps and then start using them for other
purposes just to put the location of
your of your business so
we had a huge spike on the on the
traffic and we had to like include some
authentication to avoid that but we had
an outage due to that problem also
people will use your service in ways
that you were not designed and people
will actually abuse their service by
hacking your system by getting inside
and bring him down to your database when
you rely suspected very common to have
like SQL injections that suddenly delete
your entire user data table and you can
access your service anymore in fact even
Google fails every now and then you
barely notice it because it fails very
little but it fails so the thing that we
introduced to your account for that
failure is service levels it's not
avoiding error is introducing ever in
your system in a way that you can
account for it so that even if error
exists your suit your users can mostly
operate and use your service in a way
that it was designed for those concepts
are probably the most important thing
but I'm introducing today but it's like
they're pretty much in every single
literature that we have written like in
the two essary books it's a service
level indicator it's a metric this is
the first concept that we're introducing
it's basically a definition of an
attribute of your system
an attribute of your system being a way
that your user is used in your system
it's exactly what it what it says it's
like it's an indicator of how the
service is performing at a certain point
in time an example of that would be like
the proportion of HD HTTP GET requests
the you can air on your home page there
are 200 300
400 excluding a certain measure that is
measure at the load balancer that is
just the indication of how the service
is performing a servant level objective
is a service level indicator with a
specific goal so a goal could be that
99.9 percent of those requests are
successful in a certain period of time
like 28 days there is another concept
which is service level agreement which
is basically a contract that you have
between you and the users of your
service that are paying for it in a way
that like if you miss the SLO if you run
out of every budget then your users get
a certain type of compensation so now
that we have a definition of an
indicator and we have a goal for that
indicator like a certain level how can
you find that level so a way to find the
that first goal if you don't have any
any data of your service like your new
introducing your SLO so the way that you
can do is look at your past the expected
performance that you have in the present
is the performance that your user have
experienced in the recent past so that's
something that you can use to define
that first level of performance that
their service is providing it's
something that you should not maintain
ad infinitum something that you should
change because expectations change past
performance is not an indicator of
future results so you should go back and
see how the system is performing and at
a certain time in the present only to
change when think when when the
environment changes imagine trying to
get your phone out of the pocket and
it's an iPhone 2 and then connected into
a GPRS network right now I'm trying to
download your
favorite website it will probably a
nightmare and then you will hate that
experience so things change even though
you don't feel that the website is
changing they're loading it with
JavaScript that are loading it with like
more requests in the background so
things changing in time and therefore
you should be analyzing how those things
are changing and get to the future so
now that we have a certain level in
which we can assume that the service is
going to fail we have for example a 99%
2/9 for your service you have a
certainly way in which your service can
fail so the point is not to avoid that
failure is to embrace it and once you
embrace it you can use it for other
things like you can test your
environment you can test your users you
can do a/b experiment you can increase
the certain level at which you add it's
the speed at which you release new
features you can put that feature that
you were not expecting to put because
it's a little bit too risky but then you
can put it there and see how your users
are affected so now we have what we are
trying to to measure and how we are
trying to measure so let's talk about
how we alert on those measurements that
we have first of all we said that a
symptom is anything that you can be met
you can measure with a lesser though so
a way to express that that SLO would be
to measure like the app time of your
service
that's the availability so you measure
how long it stays up compared to how
long is this app and stays down that is
fantastic for a single machine but then
we go back into the complexity of the
systems like once you have your load
balancers to the front they'll have all
the thousand machines responding in the
back it's almost impossible to identify
that binary in which you're like
identifying their time so what we do
instead is
we define the availability in a complex
system as the amount of errors that you
receive when you're receiving traffic
versus all the total requests that are
valid when you're receiving those
requests so then you have your system
you have your SLRs you put a proverb
your proverb is testing your machine
every every five minutes or every one
minute and then your system is telling
you that your system is up you have your
availability numbers that are like 100%
we're done right no we're not right
imagine that you have a consistent job
is running every minute and it's like
loading your service 10 seconds of every
minute at the beginning of the minute
and then you put your approver that is
only paid testing your service every
other minute and they are inter live
with each other in a way that only
you're getting the good things but not
the bad things that is possible to
happen so in order to increase the
resolution that you have that you obtain
from your proffer the thing that we
recommend is increasing the number that
the resolution of those props without
increasing too much the traffic that you
are creating another way that we can use
is measure the availability at the
application level you instrument your
application to save low ups on the
request that you're receiving and the
responses that you're providing and you
can increase the the coverage of the
measurement of availability the problem
that you're introducing over here is
that you only account for the good
requests that you receive all the
requests that died at the at the at the
local and state level or die because the
network was down you won't be able to
see them there's an expression that I
put over here
is essentially prometheus expression in
which like you it just like you put this
in your in your Prometheus code and you
can see like the availability in the
right numbers like essentially counting
the requests that you received
discarding the request there are four
hundreds and then doing the calculation
another way to you know the possibility
on how to measure the availability is by
doing it at the load balancer level you
put your measurement in the load
balancer which is like account the ratio
that you receive come the responses that
you respond versus all the responses
that come back from your back-end web
servers and are not 200 and wallah you
have a measurement right we made it we
have all the symptoms that are
calculated we are trading alerts that
are paging every time that we are seeing
an error on the availability of our
system and then happy users not so far
once you start paging for every single
ever that your service is saying your
basically counting every drop as if it's
worth the same and that's not reality
like a machine that is dying in the
background your load balancer is not
fast enough to move to a healthy machine
your high availability service is not
accounting for those little glitches
that happen over there you don't want to
page for every single failure that
occurs in your system what you want to
page is for the SLO burn is the ratio at
which the error is being produced so big
floods of errors are accounted for small
errors occurring in isolation are not
accounted for how do we do that we
introduce a little bit of math the thing
that you want to calculate is the burn
rate at which you have like you define a
threshold in which are your error rate
is basically burning your
entire ever budget at the end of the
window in this case if we have an
average QPS of 1000 what we can do is
like if we have an SLO of 99 over a
period of a week we calculate that we
have a number of 604 million turtle
queries and therefore we have a number
of permissible errors of six million
plus the idea of calculating the fast
burn error rate is by calculating that
threshold on how many QP SS are per
second in this case the threshold would
be about 70 hours per second that your
system is producing so what do you do
next
is defined over that threshold you
define two regions the one region in
which like you're fast burning of error
budget is going to consume the entire
error budget at the end of your window
and then the area in which you have a
slow burn but at the end of the error
window at the end of the time window
you're going to just burn a select
smaller amount of that error budget
however consuming that error budget in a
small amount will also produce like
introduced some problems which is that
you will not have that error budget to
experiment and to do other things so
what you want to do is in the second
part is you want to introduce a level of
in notification like send a ticket to
your operational team so that on Monday
when they get to work they can take a
look at it but they don't have to
respond immediately on the other hand
when you receive a fast burn alert that
means that you are affecting your users
in a way that your error budget is going
to be consumed by the end of that window
and therefore is something that the
system is being affected by is something
that is like like if it goes immediately
to failure that line that blue line by
the way I didn't ask but anybody is like
colorblind anyway the line on the top
that says fast burn that is a lie in in
this case is a line that is like very
similar to the threshold or
ever bites of consumption but if you
have a full outage that line probably is
like almost vertical unless you're in
the middle of the night and then you're
just receiving very small QPS but still
it's something that you would like to
respond because the moment that you
increase the QPS that line will be
almost vertical and will be consuming
your budget almost immediately
this is an expression that I put over
here is basically Prometheus so it
calculates the errors or sorry the
errors that are produced in in a period
of an hour you would get paid when the
amount of increased errors in that
period of an hour is bigger than that
threshold line of the area budget and
there's here the calculations that we
that we put before it's like the number
of QPS that we're receiving in a period
of time compared to the to your target
availability over the period of 10 to 24
hours so putting it all together
once you define how you want to measure
sorry what do you want to measure in
your service through your SL ice and
your SLO so one you have your
availability target that you have
defined either through past experience
or through observability of your service
what you want to do is not forget
observability like that all system that
you're using right now which by the way
I tend to call it the
Nagios problem it's like when Nagas came
out it was so easy to just install it in
your machine put an SNMP server and then
immediately you would get by your CPU
may trace your memory metrics your swaps
consumption like don't do not forget
about that it's something that it might
be important to do correlation and to
debugging your problems but essentially
like use the four pillars of
observability that we have described
before there are like blocks metrics
traces exceptions code files like
collect that information it will help
you to maintain that information to do
correlation and causation and root cause
analysis but nothing to the alert to the
system based alert system by doing that
he transitioned slowly like talk to you
to the team that is writing the software
and see if you have collecting your
collecting logs talk to the people that
are in charge of the load balancers if
you are using Google Cloud many of the
load balancers automatically ingest that
information into stat driver so figure
out what is the information that you
want to pass on what is the the one of
the like metrics that are defining how
your service is operating introduce a
couple of SL eyes on them introduce a
capital of SL O's that define your
objectives and then start measuring
their availability the transition
assumes that your teams are having all
kinds of like it works in a coherent
manner like introducing SL O's and
targeting availability requires the
development team in order to do the
thing that we were doing that we were
talking about like once you buy burn
your ever budget and you don't have
available reliability leeway left you
have to get your teams to development
teams to slow down in putting new
features slow down in like pushing for
those releases that may increase your
risk like at Google we have defined we
have identified that introducing new
changes and even if it's configuration
changes releasing new binaries increase
the ever that it's been added to your
system so add a system based alert lower
the stability of the of the system based
alert in the beginning and then
identified if you have an outage that is
been paging through your cost base alert
if the system base alert is also paging
identify the moments that your alerts
are firing in the cost based alert what
are not firing in your in your system
based alert through your SLO maybe your
users are happy and you're just paging
your operators without any reason and
slowly transition to increase the
severity of the SLO base alerting system
and decrease the severity of the of the
cost based alert once you feel more
comfortable with it the next thing that
you should do is those goals that we
have defined before analyzing the
analysis tumf is done through critical
user journeys so get to your service
talk to your developers identify work
the things that are extremely important
to your service and based on those
identify some of the SL ice that
increasingly will sorry that over time
will increase in complexity in the
beginning you should aim for like the
basics like the simple things that
provide you the biggest amount of him
for me
but later on you will like introduce
more complex as allies like a system
like in which you have to do a login it
may have certain interactions with like
taking authorization tokens bringing
them back calling some other databases
some external service for payments so
increase their the complexity of your
service once you get comfortable with
that and the next thing that you do is
your rinse and repeat SL loss should
never be set on stone it they change
with your users they change with with
the development of your features and
your service with the growth of your
service with the importance of it like
you may be the leader in the market and
a lot of people are relying on you so
you need to like move and create that
culture of like revisiting and reviewing
what you have defined so that you can
move as your service moves and on that
there's much more information about this
topic in the two books that we have
published there is a URL over there
where you can actually get the copies of
the book in PDF and we have also
Coursera course that goes through the
entire workflow on how to develop those
SL eyes those are lows in much more
detail you have other URLs so that you
can access it over it and with that
you made it to the end
[Applause]
[Music]